تفجير سد نوفاكا خوفك في اوكرانيا يعادل
تاثيره تفجير قنبله نوويه تداعيات كارثيه
بيئيه ومائيه وصحيه وانسانيه واقتصاديه قد
تمتد عقودا طويلا للتعافي من عواقبه مع
استمرار تدفق مياه نهر الدينيبرو الذي
يقسم الاراضي هناك الى مناطق تسيطر عليها
كل من روسيا واوكرانيا
عواقب اخرى محتمله لهذا التبجير هي تاثيره
على محطه
النوويه التي يعتمد نظام التبريد فيها على
مياه هذا السد ما يهدد العالم بكارثه
نوويه الخطر ايضا يكمن بما تحمله المياه
المتدفقه فبعد التدمير الجزئي للسد تدفقت
عشرات الالاف من الالغام الروسيه التي
كانت مزروعه في المنطقه الى بلدات سكنيه
وتسرب نحو 150 طنا من زيت المحركات لنهر
دينيبرو فاصبحت المياه التي كانت تستخدم
للزراعه والصناعه والاستهلاك العام ملوثه
بمواد كيميائيه ومياه الصرف الصحي ما
سيؤدي في المستقبل الى انتشار الاوبئه
والفيروسات والامراض